[Music]
and in also we'll talk about how to
review notebooks with the end i'm
package and ian you're five minutes have
just started oh that's this one this
work you can hear me yeah good perfect
hands up if you use jupiter notebooks
hands up if dipping them with different
versions is easy right
so diffing your jupiter notebook is hard
attributes a notebook is a collection of
is a Jason document containing code and
visual output so text output and
graphical outputs with a lot of metadata
like the timestamp when cells are being
run which sequence each cell is in if
you run the same cell many times it says
that it's so one two three four five and
in counts up so if you run the same code
multiple times with the same output you
would have different notebooks due to
the metadata alone and if you generate
different graphical outputs the
graphical output might render slightly
differently especially between different
machines for the same code so you end up
with different binary and being encoded
in the document and if you try to do a
diff using the diff tool you get to that
kind of rubbish being shown on screen
which is the the encoding of an image
inside this JSON file when you've got
200 cells lots of images inside it
everything gets terribly confused and
your diff output goes on for pages and
pages you can't make any sense of it and
you hate it it wouldn't it be nice if we
had a nice dipping tool one of your
options is to use Jupiter NBD convert
and then export the notebook to a Python
file and then you've got two Python
files for two different versions of your
your get code and you can use a regular
text-based if but then you lose your
graphical output and what we get with MB
dime is a brownish it's not my project
this is one that I've started using and
we get an in-browser graphical diff it
will highlight differences in the code
and it'll highlight differences in the
visual output so you can do this
code ding any web-browser nice and easy
because NB time understands all of the
metadata in the Cupidon notebook you can
use it at the command line as well and
then you do diffing as you would at the
command line but it will strip out all
of the metadata and it will do things
like summarize the binary output from
the base64 encoding and snip it to one
line rather than many pages and it will
summarize figures know summarized code
diffs and you get the different code
that's relevant in different colors on
one line all of the command line and it
goes all the way through to having a
three-way merge diff tool inside the web
browser so everything that you're
expecting to do with with code inside
pycharm or whichever version control
system you've been using in the past you
can do now in jupiter notebook in the
web browser I started using it recently
for a two hundred cell notebook
it just works brilliant made my life
really easy and I could compare and if
somewhere remote team member and my own
even though a lot of the notebook had
been modified I was really happy with
them I remember seeing a couple of years
ago it to come on a lot in the meantime
I'm just super happy that it just worked
and I thought it was worth sharing that
cuz it might make your life easier as
well that's it thank you very much
[Applause]
right thanks yeah so Tex
depersonalization we started this
conference with a talk on gdpr about
personal data how we have to be careful
with that and this is also an issue with
texts so where I work at kpn we get a
lot of incoming text data customers chat
with us with our customer service they
call us and we can then do space
speech-to-text on that or they email us
all this kind of stuff and they tell us
a lot about themselves they often tell
us what their name is what their phone
number is where they live what their
bank account number is and yeah we have
to be very careful with this information
because this puts a lot of constraints
on what we can do with it where we can
store it how long we can store it etc
and actually for a lot of the things we
want to do with that for our analysis
for our modeling we don't really care
about this personal data we if we're
trying to classify what your problem was
we don't care much what your name was or
where you live so it might be a good
idea to put some something in between
there that kind of filters out all this
all this personal data so that we are
you know as analysts are much much safer
when we're working with this data so
that's what I'll be talking about we
built a little package Python package
called the person and essentially works
like this so if you want to remove stuff
from text there's essentially two ways
you can do that you can black list
everything that you think is bad or you
can white list everything you think is
good huh we started with black list
thing because it's kind of the easy
thing to start with you try to recognize
numbers and names and this kind of stuff
but there's a lot of problems cuz you
need to know exactly what all the stuff
is that you want to block and these
lists will never be exhaustive so you're
always going to have problems with stuff
slipping through so in the end we
actually went for white listing because
it's safer but you had to have other
challenges there because you need a full
list of all the words in the language
that you want to let through and
something like Dutch for instance you
have compound words which are difficult
I have a lot of domain-specific words
and people might misspell words etc so
it is all going to be caught if you're a
white listing the first problem is where
to actually find a white list that
describes say the Dutch language it was
not so easy I googled but I couldn't
find one so I was like okay where do I
get this
but then I realized if I just start up
my computer it actually knows pretty
well what Dutch is if I just open my
word processor and I type in something
that says in Dutch my name is Jakob and
my SIM cards been blocked it understand
very well that that's that name is not a
Dutch word and that this has been
misspelled because it has spell checker
so couldn't we use that to do the
personalization because the problem is
very much related so I figured out how
does Libre Office in this case do this
and it has something underneath called
Han spell which is the spell checker for
a Thunderbird Firefox etc and it comes
with two files one file with a list of
like stem words which all have a bunch
of flags and then a file that defines
will be flat all these flags mean so for
example it this helps you understand
that if you have the word beer this is
why a flag tells you that you can make
that into beer chip and so with this you
can you can understand you can reverse
engineer this to get a whole list of all
the Dutch words in all the words in the
Dutch language and then we add some
domain-specific words like kpn which the
dictionary doesn't know I mean some
slang because a lot of people when
they're chatting they don't write very
Dutch very well and then yeah we have
our whitelist and we we can we can do
what we set out to do which is
depersonalized attack so anything that's
not in our white lace we filter it out
and then with hunt spell there's a
couple of other cool things it has a
Python wrapper so you can run your words
through that if you're not sure about
them to for example do deal with this
problem with compound words it Dutch
choose the language we have compound
words you can concatenate words forever
and make new words
so actually an exhaustive list of Dutch
words is it's not possible but the hunt
spell has two rules for this
concatenation and you can just run your
your words through there if you're not
sure we also did some auto correction on
misspelling a lot of people were having
problems spelling the word opponent
meant in Dutch you see all the variants
these were very common so we do some
auto correction here and yeah so we wrap
this all up in a little package
it works it's really simple as it gives
you a class called the person you can
apply various parts of the package to
your text and this is what you get this
is my name is Peter blah blah blah and
it filters out the name the email the
postal code phone number etc and the
idea is to have this on github pretty
soon we're not quite there yet but it
will be on the kpn data science lab
github so look out for that if you're
interested exactly so my name is amar
Klein and I'm here to tell you that web
assembly is awesome so out of curiosity
how many of you have heard of web
assembly before and who've you know what
web assembly is so I've worked to do
okay so web assembly is an open standard
for executable codes and it's being
developed by people from Google
Microsoft Apple Mozilla and so basically
everyone is involved to make this happen
it's a very compact binary format so
it's very memory efficient but it also
has a textual human readable
representation and there's a one-to-one
relationship to it so you can always
convert one into the other which is
great for things like debugging web
assembly is also fast it's a very
low-level format as the name might
suggest but it's just high-level enough
so that it can represent platform
agnostic code and that means that it's
relatively easy to convert webassembly
into actual machine code and yeah the
code that will then run is also very
fast it's also safe it needs to run on
the web so it's safe and many of you may
not know but it already works in all
major web browsers actually it has been
working in all major web browsers for
almost a year so you can actually
already play with it and several other
communities like the rest community and
some others are embracing web assembly
to move to the web and so people are
coding apps in rust and running
in the browser for instance of course
for peyten we cannot really do it that
way because by tonie's interprets its
but there are other ways that we can use
it I think so another thing that's good
to know that's webassembly is not
limited to the web it's initially
designed for the web but you can just as
well use it as an intermediate
representation for representing
executable codes in a platform agnostic
way for desktop or mobile applications
eventually so my question something that
I've been asking myself but I also want
to ask to you
how will we what will we do with web
assembly so how can we make use of web
assembly but also what role can pite and
play as web assembly becomes more
popular because it will so some of the
things that I've been doing myself
together with window bauman we've
created some tools to work with web
sembly in peyten we've done this insight
EP PCI project which is a pure part and
compiler infrastructure and with
functionality to read write and inspect
part in web so many modules so we can
actually load a module
expect it to see what imports it
requires and also what functions it
exports and we can actually compile the
web so many module into executable
machine code we can execute it inside
the same part in process and we can have
the web seminar module call back into
Python functions and that opens up a lot
of cool possibilities once it eventually
works reliably we just started it but so
ensure that website is awesome it's
going to come and it's going to be
awesome
and we need to think about what we're
going to do and if you're interested
come talk to me thanks
[Applause]
so I wanted to give a very quick
lightning talk about something that you
might have noticed around the edges that
I've been doing this weekend and that
Ian has been joining me in doing this
weekend just to introduce ourselves I'm
James I'm from them focus at the end of
the Lightning talks before the closing
notes I'll tell you a little bit more
about Numb focus and how Heidi Amsterdam
fits into the global pie data community
ian is one of the chairs of PI data
London and one of the one of the leaders
in this community and one of the things
we've been doing this weekend is trying
to remove barriers to contributing to
open source so some of you are in the
session that we did in the green room
earlier in which in helped a couple
people with their first open source
contribution if you want to talk about
that briefly so at PI data London and a
couple of previous conferences have been
building up this idea of a short session
30 minutes making your first open source
contribution so not checking out code
and getting pandas running on your
machine in a full development
environment and then editing the code
and then following the committee
requirements to get it back and
committed but instead working in the
github web interface to fix some
documentation typos in a project so a
super simple thing you can do from your
own web login you make a change you do a
pull request back to the project owner
they accept the documentation gets
rebuilt and then the typos she fixed
cleared the available online
straightaway so this morning we fixed to
one word typos trivial little jobs to do
but for two people who hadn't done that
before and then the documentation was
live afterwards on the TDD a project and
it was accepted back by my collaborator
Nick back in Edinburgh and within
minutes of the push is being made so it
was really nice just to get some people
making their first contributions to the
open source world with it in London and
elsewhere before and I want to be more
of that so beyond just the technical
mechanisms of making an open source
contribution we really want to address
everything that stops any one of you
from making a contribution we did a get
workshop right afterwards in which we
talked about certain things problems
people run into with git we ran out of
time but we're gonna go into ways that
we can use git and github more
effectively and this is one other
technical barrier but I wanted to share
with you with the remaining few seconds
I have a story about my life and making
an open-source contribution and
something that I know a lot of you face
and one of the other non-technical
reasons that we need to focus so heavily
on removing these barriers so you know
I'm vice president and um focus I've
been to a lot of Pi din events I've
spoken a even have my own open source
project it's called GM Pi it's an open
source mesh optical route planning tool
it's one of the first tools of its kind
in that industry I'm actually on this
tool as the main technical contributor
telling participants from companies like
orange and Facebook and academic
institutions like University of Torino
how to build industrial great software
and yet sometimes when I can try to
contribute something sometimes where I
have a bug-fix I'm kind of nervous about
it so here's a bug-fix that I did late
last year or early last year rather and
I found a little bug in a library called
curio and I put it on and I said it's
driven by stupid example I kind of put
myself down when I was doing it and you
know
Nathaniel Smith who's one of the core
developers for numpy actually saw this
before the the owner of this project saw
it and he said oh do you have an example
and I tried to put myself down again
saying oh don't worry if I'm wrong about
this and at the end of an interesting
thing happened where he said oh I only
just realized it's you James which on
the one hand kind of makes you feel good
and the other hand you're like well I
kind of hope that everybody who's on the
project gets treated with the same
niceness it's not just because you know
that person that they're treated nicely
and one interesting thing that happened
was in the development of this library I
decided my own library I decided maybe
we need to add something to numpy and so
I tweeted it in Nathaniel who whom I've
seen many times since I was like does it
make sense to add DB to Lin and Lin to
DB to numpy I know that
Syfy dot Constance has lambda2 nu and nu
to lambda and these would be helper
functions and Nathaniel says to me I
don't know ask the mailing list and my
response is I don't want them to be mean
to me because sometimes you say hey why
don't we do this and the response is
you're the stupidest person I ever saw
don't do this I hate you and it really
puts you down and even for somebody who
knows a lot of the core contributors
who's part of this community who has
their own open-source library even I
sometimes worry about being yelled at
and this is one other mechanism that we
need to address in clearing the barriers
for you
so what I want you to do as a call to
action is tweet at me tweet it Ian
what can we do to clear any barriers
that sit between you and cockt abuse
an open-source library is it about
technology is it about github or is it
about just making it so that you feel
comfortable telling somebody you know
what I use this I think it could be
better let us know and let's see if we
can use PI data as a mechanism to
introduce more of you to open source and
the contribution side of it thank you so
I have a confession to make before going
to the talk so I guess many people use
Twitter here right today and so I want
to listen to that talk again so I'm
gonna like this to it and then right
after I read the tweet or read the
presentation I'm gonna like it because I
use you I use Twitter likes as a
bookmark feature which is kind of bad
but I'm sorry that's what I do so I'm a
inbox zero kind of guy I'm gonna come to
that
so similarly github right so github as
this star feature and I want to click
this star button like I like pandas I
guess everyone likes it yeah anyway so I
want to click that star we're done but
at the same time I don't wanna I don't
want this number to go up because I keep
I use my star report as a bookmark
feature again I want to keep going
through that list okay there are so many
interesting people wonderful people who
create awesome repos like we can be
blocked pores or it can be tools etc so
I wanna start them and I want to go back
to them see what kind of wonderful
things are there in the world but at the
same time I don't want to click start
which I know that I like I don't want to
go through the pound a second so how I
want to click star but I don't I don't
want to click the star so what do I do
so that's basically my objective so if I
can categorize github repos into smaller
lists and so so that it's manageable for
me to actually go through the
even though I have like let's say
thousand get github starter course right
so that's where that's where the product
is so can we use topic modeling latent
dirichlet allocation to do this it's
basic we can kind of start with this
analogy think of a bimodal distribution
and you can separate this bimodal
distribution into two distributions and
you can sum it up with different weights
so the hypothesis behind topic modeling
is each topic is a set of word
distributions and there are different
topics in any document so the idea is
you can devolve you can divide a
document into a set of topics with
distribution of topics for a document so
work flow github as a very easy to use
API and there are Python clients for
that so you get the read means from each
github repo and use regex spacy so space
is a NLP tool like an LP kit which you
can use to tokenize i'll amortize stem
stem the text and then finally we use a
scale on sky to do latent dirichlet
allocation yeah since this is a
lightening talk just a very small set of
results so this is one topic that I
found just earlier today awesome so what
is the topic here I guess it's awesome
and it's lists so all of these are less
awesome Linux software or some computer
vision or some semantic segmentation and
so on
so I guess topic modeling works and
something that I proved so and this is
the output that you get for each github
repo you get the list of topics and the
corresponding probabilities not
probabilities more like proportion of
topics in that document so then you so
one thing said I got to this list by
just sorting on each topic so one topic
was this
but what we can do in addition to that
is to use the table add additional
features so github right now actually
allows you to add tags custom tags and
so you can add that as a feature and
maybe I want to add the language of the
repo as a feature like Python or R and
so on and that's it and finally yeah
so why topic modeling instead why not
use dr. Wecht right so obviously deep
learning FTW so yeah for the win so
that's it thanks online shopping is far
less everybody knows if it's fashion
online shopping is boring if it's
grocery because it's time-consuming its
buying the same stuff all over and over
again and we predict that the next 10
years about one third of the grocery
shopping will be done online so that's
quite a big challenge for us and we want
to predict what will be the next basket
what I'm going to do I'm going to invite
you to a hackathon end of June the last
Friday of June at our office in a nice
moment we will have retailer data set
containing transactional data where you
can show your machine learning skills
and the assignment is to predict the
next shopping baskets of each customer
to make it easy because it's just today
we will have an operator with you for
you at the baseline model which will be
just the last basket including a f-1
scoring function and also a submission
function to our leaderboard so then you
can go crazy with modeling we will have
service for you GPUs and in the lunch
break we have a picture creature
workshop it's an extra then we have for
jewelry from industry from a behind
print royalty and ice mobile and you can
win awesome prizes and you don't see the
pictures here because they're far off
but it will be at least a trip in the
self-driving boat from somnium will be
also vouchers from a behind to do
shopping and other stuff you can't see
the date now so put it here this is our
team this is the QR code if you are
interested and you can just register it
Eventbrite would be nice if you come
many chances that thank you usually we
have to clap people away we don't have
to do that this year so these were the
lightening talk speakers so please give
one final round for all of them
[Applause]